modeling parties having tea time yes
ladies and gentlemen my name is Ryan
right hi I'm Lauren gah my sister do my
boys
hello let me just take the most
obnoxious my cockney
my name's no not to do that whatever
keep going in honor of this movie
trailer we're gonna watch it's actually
a movie clips we decided to do British
accents for a movie that is taking place
in Paris actually my bed so I'll see
should we do French accent okay I guess
you're right I want you today do you
speak French yes a little bit Oh oui
what an unfair game let's speak French
and you actually speak French and then
you want me to like try to be as good as
you risk an accent not speaking in like
oh you got ten times better author Jane
just say zis instead of T's like this is
the lego movie yeah that's the first
thing that came to mind is it illegal
we're gonna watch it do a query on go
yes ma'am number I respond to everything
you say and listen to your obedient ways
because my mother was my Oakland
Berkeley yeah my mother's Asian so
there's a subconscious reaction I have
where when you tell me to do something
I'm gonna immediately do go practice
piano oh I can't I don't have a piano I
got that one a lot
oh she wants to do the nasty I really
don't remember actually oh wait oh yeah
yeah right
I was stupid is he to fall for this like
you're supposed to be guarding this
prisoner in your lool well he doesn't
know yet that she's [ __ ] this is like
exactly what happened with you and I
oh hey oh wow
and Walter
about the boy didn't realize welcome to
do hey speak English no no no speak
English yes your favorite hospital now
she's murdered an innocent man no he
shot is she shot him in the leg he was
going my leg my leg but she still shot
an innocent guy who had nothing to do
what was going on it's true but shot in
the leg she kill him it's pretty [ __ ]
up though there's no reason to shoot him
in the leg she needs to go to the
[ __ ] Hospital do you are you actually
justifying this it's a movie she named
like dawn of the Planet of the age I
said and I thought it was really silly
comment below and how much you hate me
right now you shouldn't have done that
shouldn't have done that if any of you
cross the line I will ban you from the
channel Oh
all those cuffs are from the trailers so
I've actually seen all those clips yeah
I know but you actually just see how
like the tone in them the rhythm of this
movie plays out yeah I am something it
looks like a really cool movie I'm not a
huge Scarlett Johansson fan in general
but I don't mind her in this I mean she
could do action well have you seen
Captain America - she was great in that
so yeah you didn't love her in that no I
just don't love her in general
well like she's not one of my favorite
actresses I don't mind her but she's not
like she's not royalty
I understand hey Lauren yes we have
another clip we could watch it easy
let's watch it second clip here we go
but I have to be honest with you what
you did back there not freak me out but
it was like spark to put everyone to
sleep like that do I need to be worried
hmm
good
what the hell happening right now
minority voice hey write me know what's
down yeah I just crying I'm gonna dress
hey no no no no this is a priests car
you can't no this is not possible lady
this is a police car
Wow drive like that who never driven
before great now what you supposed to
loud yes directed wonderfully oh my god
hey another beam Ethan did we never
really die
I'm gonna tell them to stop following us
don't bother why didn't you make the car
like fly over her I don't know just move
the cars out of the way or make them
stop working I feel like she doesn't
when you asked if she why she shot that
innocent man I feel like she does not
give a [ __ ] about all the innocent
people here it sounds like a very
likable character like I don't care do
you get into car accident very real I
have so many superpowers no one could
touch me now she's the soulless [ __ ]
yeah I mean even the way she's talking
she's just like okay yeah sounds like a
very difficult performance I have a
question I have an answer so this was
she gets this drug that allows her to
use a hundred percent of her brain yes
but that also gives her superpowers well
one could argue that mind is also a form
of energy that allows you to get in
touch because everything is energy
connected Wow someone has not seen the
secret now I haven't seen the secret
I've read the book though well it's the
same thing it's all in there hanging out
comprehend what I'm saying no I do
comprehend what you're saying you mean
you don't believe in the law of
attraction I don't feel like law of
attraction is the same as like if I can
use a hundred percent of my brain then I
can like see cellular waves well we
don't know what happens whatever they
can really do whatever the [ __ ] they
want any week's gotten us almost ended a
friendship over a hypothetical
conversation can we Jesus
somebody's touchy huh Oh Donatello
neither of these are Donatello
Leonardo anyway guys if you're new to
the channel here's what you can do you
can subscribe down here with that button
and this button is Lauren's button for
her her channel i have a channel she has
a channel i have like almost 100
subscribers Wow we all came from thanks
guys
you have like four videos now yeah so
I'm on my way I have like 4 videos I'm
making moves what are you doing are you
maintaining me these are my movies I go
to the club get so many ladies yeah so I
get so many girls come with a channel
names Ryan oh hey Lauren you know what I
was thinking we should do next
shut up exactly okay spider-man swag
spider-man spoder spoderman swag
spoderman swag my bad
[ __ ] you know that's gonna look like
spider I know
anyways spider-man swag wanted a
shout-out now now well mister swag here
is your shout-out my friend ID stay
awake just see you breathing so fly my
face there's a fly in my face me really
yeah now those like part of it a little
bit you were doing I was very kinky here
this bits called ADHD Ryan uh is me
Vincent Alberta Ryan El Corte Vincent G
alcorta
Ryan if you give me a shout-out I'll
suck your dick huh I come on over and
you challenge you to it let's do this
just tell me how long it's been since
he's had sex
yup nine and a half months oh I could
have had a baby at this time you could
have I could have had a baby maybe I do
somewhere else I do just want to like
help him out and say that the the
opportunity has come up but he's just a
good guy and didn't want to take
advantage of poor lonely girls yeah
protection that's the only part that
matters is the last two words you said
no babies here
no babies Hannah babies right nope nope
cannot financially afford a kid right
now nor do I really want a kid right now
he'd probably just get on my nerves you
know but if you wanted a kid and you
couldn't find someone I totally help out
I
I don't want one right now you wouldn't
even just want like you know my sperm
have it implanted in you
no really as I was thinking Vincent
could start me off and then right before
I'm about to finish your sperm I could
give you this permanent Cup I know other
people in that I would ask for their
sperm
okay Jesus try me nice
Fabian among chia Mencia see ya hey you
guys are yeah [ __ ] hilarious
can I get a shoutout yes you can you're
[ __ ] hilarious man there's any
comedian in the room it's you
you all the way man I got nothing else
for you buddy yeah what's your picture
of that a lion in a human not it I don't
know I can't really tell oh no it's like
a baby but in two hands but the baby has
a grown man face I think that's what it
is that's weird
that's a weird picture it looks like a
man wearing a lion's head from far away
yes it does or an eagle head that's what
I'm talking about
that's [ __ ] hilarious man